hi everyone oh this is a bit very loud
maybe so my name is Marya and today I'm
gonna make an introduction until
aperture airflow I want to say that this
presentation is aimed for beginners
somebody who maybe heard about airflow
but never used that so let's start what
is there what what's airflow airflow you
can think of it as a tool to build
schedule and monitor data pipelines
built means to create schedule mean
still set specific time when the
workflow should start and monitor means
to be able to check how your workflow is
going which task failed which succeeded
why they failed for example let's also
define what's the data pipeline data
pipeline is the set of data processing
elements connected in series where the
output of one element is the input to
the next one imagine you have some data
you put it into the data processing
element simply put function and you get
transformed output that you can put into
the next function and so on so today
we're going to build very simple data
pipeline so it's going to be a toy
example but I believe it will help us to
understand and to learn main concepts of
air flow and so the project for today is
the following so imagine you are very
interested in some Python library let's
say pandas for those who don't know
pandas is data analysis and modeling
library so you're very interesting that
what you want to stay up-to-date and you
think oh maybe if I know what people
with goose with with good reputation on
Stack Overflow ask about pandas then it
will give me a good overview so you
decide to automate this process
and get fresh questions from Stack
Overflow every day to your mailbox so
let's see how how we might make a data
pipeline of this project so the first
task would be to create a table which is
Postgres table where we will store raw
questions the next step will be to
actually get data from Stack Overflow
and in a rough format for one day store
it in this table then we will filter
this data to select only a good question
so interested one interesting one and
store them as Jason in s3 okay the first
task will be to take data from s3 and
render inch tml template with this data
that eventually we're gonna send this
email and it's supposed to run every day
without us touching it okay so now we
know what we want to build let's see
what tools do we have in our disposal
like what air flow can can offer us it's
called
main concepts of air flow you some
people say it's building blocks of air
flow and there are seven of them that
we're going to learn today and use in in
our code so the first one the very first
concept is operator you can think of it
just like a worker something that knows
how to perform a task and has all the
tools to make it right for example a
specific for air flow you can have
Python operator it knows how to run
Python code Postgres operator knows how
to connect to Postgres database and run
SQL queries there
bash operator knows how to run bash
commands etc right so the second main
important concept is dead it states for
directed a cyclic graph but it's just
protocol it just like set of
instructions where you define which
tasks should follow which one what to do
one task failing how many times you want
to retry things like that that's right
next concept is task itself its job
performed by the operator
the first one is important it's
connection connection its
secrets or credentials to external
external systems for example both grass
connection would consist of ports a host
user passwords right and it's all can be
stored in the airflow database securely
right so you don't need to worry about
how to how to securely get it there next
its hooks hooks its are very very useful
I think because they they give us a
common interface for this external
services right because if you need to
connect to a Postgres you would normally
use some external library like psycho PG
or something but here you can just use a
hook provide connection that you've
stored in the airflow and run your
queries and as for example s3 hook
should look very similar to both grass
hook just with different connection and
parameters fine
so one workin service variables super
simple it's just like environmental
variables any arbitrary chunks of data
that you might need to store and the
very last one is XCOM XCOM stays for
cross communication between tasks and if
you follow the best practices of
building workflows your tasks should be
independent or it important it should
not share any state but sometimes you
need to share a little bit of data
between tasks and XCOM is the tool to do
that and will you you will see today how
one might use it ok so now we have our
goal right the pipeline we wanna build
and
have the tools that airflow provides
let's just go and we can go start
building the pipeline and the first
thing like but you need usually students
stole everything and have it deployed
somewhere but all this is out of scope
of this presentation but in the git
repository that I provided in the
beginning you can find some links that
can help you get started but let's just
imagine we have everything installed and
the first thing I do before building the
pipeline is usually store those
connections and variables that I already
know in airflow UI I have a small demo
for you to show how it might look like
hopefully Internet's working fine
so here is just like what I'm starting
the web server locally so since its
local I can go to my local host and this
is how the UI looks like in the admin
tab you have connections and variables
let's check the variables I already
created them you see s3 bucket stack
overflow IDs secret and the tag so let's
change it upon this this is how so
remember all this variables we will need
them and also connections for this
project we need two connections Postgres
connection and s3 connection here you
can see how how it looks which parameter
it takes and yeah we say it cool so this
is all we need for now so let's go and
step by step implement them pipeline
okay remember the first task is to
create questions table for that we will
need to post rest connection because we
need to create table in this database
and Postgres operator if this operator
knows how to write how to how to work
with this database in
here I prepared like a some cold I hope
you can see it so all the all-important
imports are done and this is how we
usually instantiate a deck our
instructions you need to give it a an ID
and also default arguments so maybe the
most interesting argument is like the
schedule interval how often do you wanna
run it here I say daily you can say
weekly hourly or use cron syntax so
let's go and implement our first task is
you see it's using Postgres operator it
has it should have a ID and I just use
Postgres connection here remember we
created us in the UI and since it knows
how to run SQL we need to provide SQL
query here just create a table very nice
our first task is ready so the second
task is to store that would take data
from airflow from star colourful API and
we will store it in in this table for
this widow again it's Postgres
connection variables and python operator
because we will write a Python function
that we will ask our alpha or airflow to
to run
I prepared here some functions for you
and what I want to show here is how to
get variables from the from airflow it's
very simple syntax to just say variable
get and refer it by name right there are
other variables that I'm using here like
tag and stackoverflow credentials so
this is the first function and the
second function is inserting questions
into database here I want to show you
how to you use Postgres hook again super
simple just Postgres hook give it a
connection ID
and it has very nice method just run and
I give it a query that I've on the run
insert questions query and parameters of
this query cool so yeah this is the
function that we were just also notice
how it's easy to use Postgres hook you
don't need to use psycho PG you worry
about the logic now we just take this
function that we created and go and
create one more task in our dag it's
using Python operator because we need to
write Python function and I just provide
Python color ball here super easy nice
done second task
the third one now we've taken data from
the from the table filter in it and
storing is Jason and in s3 so here we
will need Postgres connection Postgres
hook and two new things
s3 connection and s3 hook and of course
brighton operator to run it all for us
let's look at the so the first function
is actually not very important what's
here you can see i'm again using
Postgres hook and the one that we
actually going to use in the deck is
right questions to s3 here when i show
you how to use s3 hook excuse me
so also not just how similar it is to
Postgres hook i just need to provide
connection and use a specific method for
this hook nice let's go and write our
cert task which is writing questions to
a stream I just provide called a Python
variable by controllable and it's done
the force one it's when we gonna take
data from s3 and render HTML template
with this data for again ruling is s
reconnection and hook we need Python
operator in the new thing that we're
gonna
now is XCOM because I'm when after
rendering template is just a string I
don't want to store it anywhere I'm just
gonna pass it to the next task using
XCOM and let me show you how it's done
so there's the last function render
template please notice how that we use
this additional context here this
context do you give us access to the
airflow internal database right so we
can push something into this database
let's see so first we need get the task
instance from the context and then we
need to push this rendered template
which is just a value of the template
and give it a key some identifier so
that the next task knows how to what to
look for so nice let's add this to our
instructions write an operator provide
callable and additional parameter which
is provide context through a very
exciting blast last step is to send
emails take this HTML send emails and
here we just need XCOM to get data from
the previous task and email operator
that knows how to send emails
let's look so here here I'm using email
operator it takes parameters like email
when you want to send it here I created
some temporary email for the purposes of
this demo and I need contacts so provide
context yes please and it takes one more
parameter which is subject let's write
some subject here look I can use the
ginger template and here
airflo knows how to handle that so DC
stays for it's just like date so my
email on each date will have slightly
different subjects with different email
and HTML content again I'm using ginger
templates to get tasks instance this
time XCOM pull and I need to say from
which tasks I want to pull data from the
previous one render template see the
name and the key HTML content nice so
this is this is our task that we wrote
here in you can see how I define the
pipeline where I say like it's all
should run in in a serious there are
many other options you can split and
branch but right now it just just just
like that so you can see our dock is
actually ready our pipeline is ready
it's very simple very reasonable and I
have also a small demo to show you how
it might look like to run it let's see
just a second maybe I can make it a bit
slower no I can make it slower so it
will be probably fast so this is how how
you can see your pipeline in the in the
airflow UI so you can see how many times
it's run was the schedule interval was
the name and you can also trigger it
from here
which I'm gonna do now ok our pipeline
is Runyan al green means it's running
it's more successful the next task is
inserting questions so it's scheduled
its Runyan and it failed so we can check
why it failed logs are very helpful here
so I can see that I actually misspelled
a variable name
can quickly go and fix that and try to
resume this task call so this task is
queued now it was successful the next
task is writing questions to s3 I
actually have s3 bucket open here so I
can show you that actually on the day
when I made a demo it's it added
additional JSON and it looks like just
metadata of questions very nice now
we're gonna use this to render template
let's check how other other tasks are
doing render template and send email
done awesome so I also want to show you
that email actually arrived to my
temporary we make mailbox from me
questions on that date there were only
three interesting questions based on my
parameters yeah and it would be nice to
get it every day nice so this is it and
let's sum up what we learned today so
first we learnt was what a passionate
airflow that is the tool to build
scheduled and monitor data pipelines we
learnt what's the data pipeline it's a
set of data processing elements or
functions where the input output of one
element is the input to the next one
also we learnt main concepts of air flow
like that task operator X comps etc and
we wrote our first data pipeline so yeah
thank you very much we also wanna say
that usually in the real world data
pipelines our pipelines are much more
complex and much more useful and also
the air flow itself developing every day
so there are many more operators hooks
other tools in air flow that you might
use you also might write your own ones
also you can set complex triggering
rules you even can trigger your dag from
your code so there are many many things
you can do is it I just encourage you to
try it once maybe universe like several
times yeah thank you very much for being
very nice audience if you want to get in
touch with me here's my email
thanks right now have a microphone so
the my password introduction wasn't
quite record which I'm happy about
thank you very much for the akkad was
very interesting for me to see and I'll
be certainly looking into it in the
future now we're up to questions we're
actually five minutes early so there's
much more time for questions please
raise your hand I'll just come over to
you for any question yeah thank you for
your talk I have a question how can you
debug the stuff it's only possible to
lower the lot logging or it's uh only
any possibilities yeah yeah I think like
Logan is very helpful like this is
usually how I do that I think at the
backwards login or you can of course run
it locally right see all your pipelines
you can write like run locally or using
option so yeah I just usually try to
have some unit tests on my tasks right
or on my functions as well you can run
your your functions
independency from the DAC but the past
what you want to debug if it's like
failing then logs are probably the best
place to cool
any other questions I I do have a
question if some of the steps in this
pipeline are computationally heavy and
the result can be cached is there a way
to do that I'm actually don't really
know about like the cash in but
computationally so older your pipeline
can be distributed right and you also
can run the task in parallel so on many
machine so it's like very conventional
heavy you might need to distribute that
it's good to after each task is
succeeded or finished to store the data
that was outputted to somewhere so this
is what I can offer here right and where
else are precautions in your example
imagine if you had a two colleagues and
one of them so both are interested in
those overflow questions but one of them
would only be interested in having a one
message per day or one HTML page per day
and then another Kalika in one per hour
I'm in your example could you adapt that
to have the same graph but with the
different scheduling or what you end up
in multiple graphs I think you will end
up with multiple pipelines or maybe you
can have this pipeline running and like
splitting and for for it it would stop
like four four one probably a leaf like
for it for one person like if there is
email operator and for the next one it
will continue like running every hour so
but I think like I would do it to five
plus maybe there's a better way to do
that so
I would suggest - previously we you
talked about distribution of tasks let's
assume that I don't want to go into just
a single cloud scenario what would you
suggest to use steady SSH operator I
guess do you have an experience with
that one no unfortunately I don't have
experience like with SSH operator and I
don't really know if I understood your
question like what do you mean like
different clouds yeah so for example if
I want to distribute the tasks which are
computation heavy among different clouds
and I use so for example if I want to
exploit AWS as a Google cloud platform
I've seen that different implementations
to address particular cloud platforms
but if I want to be independent of that
so to avoid one vendor lock-in for
example do you have any suggestion for
them well you can write your own
operator that will be will handle all
that like and go to all the vendors that
you would like so it's very extensive
but extensible so you can you can just
rise from all operator Thanks soon yeah
I was just about to ask the other side
of the room and they may be having any
questions you still have five minutes we
have time for everybody so I'll just get
like actually I don't have a question
but I wanted to ask you just to scroll
to the beginning so that we can note
again the github link yeah sure
thank you very much for your
presentation was very very interesting
and I have a question that if you would
like to have something that now is not
implemented it's not in our flow what
you would like to have what I would like
to have yeah it's something that it's
not there well that's a tricky question
because I haven't thought about that so
right now I also see like that people
are writing like this for example
Postgres to post grass operator
I know s32 Postgres operator or some
other like that that combine this so you
don't need to write extra Python
functions and just use them so maybe
like just more like that but I don't
have this case for it at this moment so
I don't have ideas
thank you much and tomorrow there will
be a workshop and if you are interesting
you can are you doing the work yes yes
oh cool
very nice fellow two more minutes guys
and girls two more minutes and two we
have one one just one more question
hi first of all thanks a ton and I was
wondering how the architecture is
working as I understand that basically
you have some server running that is
executing the pipelines and the Python
code has kind of a seal ayah that you
used to add new pipelines maybe you can
expand a bit on that as far as I know
so the yes you need to have several
things deployed somewhere on the server
like database scheduler and like web
server for for the air flow right and
your code also so I'm I'm not sure like
there are many different ways you can
build at like and
set up but I never done that so I can't
give you like the definitive answer
perfect thanks is it a short one
depends on the app answer if it's a
short one or not does it integrate with
kubernetes yes it is what's a short one
thank you thank you I think Mario
deserves a round of applause for
answering the question so quickly
[Applause]